[Applaudissements]
à votre l 26 courant me faisant part de
votre intention de marier votre petite
étienette j'ai pris quelques
renseignements au sujet du monsieur très
bien dont vous m'aviez
parlé on me dit qu'il est pape de bien
des
religions parmi les plus curieuses et
les moins
catholique
c'est l'ou le 22 mai c'est un mauvais
Bourbon
fait dans un faux hangar dans un vieil
alambique C où les cathédales sont des
maisons bizarres où les prêtresses sont
des dames
framéliques où l'on parle en Browning en
rafale en dollar d'une façon
tranchante un peu
automatique drôle de façon droule de
bonomme que ce monsieur monsieur Capon
on me dit qu'il est princes de bien des
territoires parmi les plus fertiles
parmi les plus
lointains là où les terres sont grasses
généreuses et
noires ils cultive en secret éloigne ses
voisins il fait pleurer au fleurs une
perle bizarre et les montagnes entière
pleurent chaque
matin leur rivière de diamants leur Maré
de dollar
le Pau m et d'un
rapportôle de culture de
bon que ton monsieur
monsieur vois-tu gér un prince un PAP un
empereur voici à priori un parti
fortimable et qui devrait pouvoir nous
offrir le
bonheur mais il a quelque chose qui est
moins
agréable il faut que je t'avoue qu'il
aurait une
amie toute vêtue de noir nul ne voit son
visage mais chacun en a peur et tout le
monde fuit quand elle sort la nuit où
hentent les
parages curieux amis curieux
bonhomme que ton monsieur monsieur Capon
dont on dit qu'il est de bien des
religions dont on dit qu'il est prince
de bien des
territoires qui possède une
amie toute vêue de noir dont tandis que
les prince et pape et
empereur qui cultive en
secret qui cultive en
secret parle de
bonomme ce monsieur mon monsieur
Capon curieux
bonhomme que ton monsieur monsieur
Capon monsieur
[Musique]
Capon